thank you now when first of all to thank
you all for this debate and also for
your support a fun independent
investigation after the murder of the
Jonas Daphne Connor yet it's yeah just
this need to be done the new Commission
is very clear on such a need in the two
first weeks in office the president of
the Commission has sent a clear message
to the multis authorities we did the
same in different phone call from the
vice president version of I myself to
the Minister of Justice
Oh Anne Bonny she and I have sent a
letter to the Minister of Justice
yesterday more than that Europol is at
the disposal of the multis authorities
to take part in the investigations and
we have seen some progress in the
investigation due to the presence also
of europe own and we will continue to
follow the progress in the
investigations we need to do that not
only for Daphne Cavanaugh Margaret CFO
is family but to defend our values in
the urban Union I want to say that the
protection of the journalists because I
have many questions about that is first
of all of course a competence of the
Member States but the Commission must
take us on some initiatives to support
the media pluralism and to support also
independent journalists that work in all
the Member States and will continue to
do that and we will enhance our
capacities to do that then we need to
control a correct implementation of
justice reforms after the country
specific recommendations adopted by the
Council of 9 july 2019 in my letter
I have insists on the independence of
judiciary with safeguards for judicial
appointments and dismissals with a real
separate for secular office the
Commission will present an evaluation on
the process before
and propose concrete actions the
Commission has a toolbox to address rule
of law concerns and we are ready to make
use of it I recall that the Commission
did introduce infringement proceedings
against Malta for non transposition of
the fault anti-money laundering
directive with success as the situation
evolves we will consider which
instruments are appropriate including a
possible application of the rule of law
framework if it's needed and of course
on about all those reforms we encourage
the Maltese authorities to consult the
Venice Commission on all draft
legislation third about the investor
citizenships scheme in the supranational
risk assessment published in July 19 the
Commission is highlighted does
citizenship investment programs and
investor of residence schemes as so know
as golden passport and golden visas and
tailored significant money laundering
threat the January 2019 Commission
report on investor citizenship and
residence schemes India / Union
highlights that their schemes inherently
raise money laundering concerns awarding
citizenship is a prerogative of the
Member States however member states must
were exhausting their powers in the
sphere of nationality if due regard to
European Union law European Union
citizenship brings together rise to all
Member States providing solidarity
together member states create the
conditions for enjoying a you
citizenship this common achievement
should not be exploited by individual
member states risky investor schemes we
evaluate
for legislation is needed to find
against the abuse of golden passport and
if we must introduce infringement
proceedings to conclude we need to
enhance the culture of the rule of law
in all the Member States in the European
Union and if we want to speak about the
rule of law outside European Union it's
needed to deliver to do the job at home
it's the reason why the Commission will
organize and will set up a new mechanism
with an annual report on the rule of law
in all the Member States without any
discrimination it will be the occasion
of a real political debate in the
council and also in the parliament we
have such a process about the budgetary
situation of all the Member States it's
time to have the same political debate
about our values about the values of the
opinion that doesn't mean the abandon of
all the other tools at our disposal we
will continue to introduce infringement
proceedings to organise dialogue on the
rule of law to pursue the article 7 for
shooters and so of course it's an
important moment today this debate
because we follow very closely the
investigations about the murder of a
journalist but I will also to thank you
for your support because we have a lot
of things to do together to protect the
rule of law to defend our values thank
you Thank You Commissioner renders
colleagues we have one motion for
resolution to wind up our debate from
six political groups our debate is now
closed
and the vote will be held on Wednesday
and can I just say that as we conclude
our debate on the murder of journalist
Daphne coruña Galicia
salute the courage of her family even
though their hearts are broken we now
have a suspension for a few minutes
until we vote at 12 thank you